[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian
columnist zoe williams and the
spectators deputy political editor katie
balls welcome to both of you so as ever
let's check out the front pages and the
eye says number 10 has defended the
prime minister insisting he is not
unwell after his unusual speech to
business leaders on monday
on the front page of the guardian the
treasury is said to be frustrated by the
way major political decisions are being
made and has called for a shake-up in
downing street
the telegraph reporting that the
astrazeneca vaccine could give longer
protection than other jabs which might
explain why the uk has so far avoided
the coveted wave affecting much of
europe
testif shopping is the headline for the
scottish edition of the metro as people
are told to get a covert test before
heading to the high street
and the financial times has fresh
allegations over david cameron's links
to the collapse financial services
company greenfield capital more people
is coming in we'll look at them as they
arrive but zoe williams and katie balls
have their choices for today and it's
starting with the eye katie
trouble at the top um what are the big
issues here
and are they
long-term meaningful
well i think we're seeing lots of issues
piling up and a narrative forming around
boris johnson which the prime minister
would not like to see and was after the
bungled speech cbi
and you you're now seeing a situation
where his spokesman has had to come out
and effectively say you know he hasn't
lost his grip i think as soon as you get
into the business of denying these
things you're not on a particularly good
place and you have an unruly party a
close vote on social care and just a
sense that uh the prime minister doesn't
really have a grip on things in the way
his party would like
yes and and uh one of the paragraphs in
the eye uh zoe warning of an
undercurrent of mistrust and a briefing
war between the between the pm's team
and uh and number eleven i mean they
need to stop this don't they do do you
think
well i mean it does remain to be seen
but it feels too late to lift it in the
butt at this point then it is so
interesting yesterday laura koonsburg
tweeted something really unusual
actually about that she was being
briefed
basically saying that the cabinet was
was at it to its end and if there wasn't
some kind of significant change in the
very near future then they were going to
take action it was it was never clear
what take action was actually going to
look like but the conservatives are
famously much more ruthless about
leaders and failing leaders than the
labour party is now obviously you know i
i
wouldn't know what's going on either in
boris johnson's mind nor in his inner
circle but
to pick up on what katie said there is
a real danger when you get into
the territory of denying that somebody's
unwell or denying that they're losing
their grip that a lot of lieutenants
have fallen in order for that to happen
you know you wouldn't get
anybody could ring up a press secretary
and say
you know
is the prime minister unwell and the
press secretary could say no and that
wouldn't be a story or if it was it
would be a confected one so to get to
the point where that's a legitimate
question which the press secretary is
taking taking seriously and newspapers
are then printing you're already on very
very dicey territory which is why people
react so discomfortedly to it you know
it's not one it's not a classic oh boris
johnson has said a thing therefore that
thing probably isn't true even though
there's an element of that um it's more
that
you know these stories are gathering
pace and the normal
guard dogs that would stop them from
happening
are either asleep or not working
so um on the on the uh in the eye front
page i can see that you've got a piece
inside katie entitled why the johnson
act is wearing thin among mps the
guardian two treasury frustration as key
plans mishandled by number 10. earlier
the mail website suggesting that number
10 is run by teenagers um so so why
might he be where he be wearing thin
among mps and is it that he doesn't have
that group of people around him like the
sir edward listers uh you know who
helped him when he was mayor of london
these sort of key adults around him
yeah i think that's definitely a factor
i think ultimately boris johnson if we
go back to that speech
on to the cbi heavily criticized worried
mps full of jokes in a different time
that could have been heralded as classic
johnson breaking the mould but when
you've got lots of problems coming up
the joke starts to wear thin pretty
quickly and i think in-depth
i think
in downing street there's a sense that
you're not necessarily um having a
situation where boris shorts and listens
to advice maybe he is being given advice
but is it by figures who he trusts
enough to actually listen to it and are
they willing to really push it when the
prime minister doesn't want to listen
because what lots of these stories have
in common is the sense that the prime
minister has pushed ahead with an
unpopular option and then had to change
course and therefore that does come back
to the advisors and i think there is an
issue in number 10.
yes and the metro are saying i'm you
know quoting i don't think it's unusual
for people on rare occasions to lose
their place in a speech that alone as
katie was saying so we would have been
absolutely fine it's all the rest of it
isn't it not least now this uh this
trouble over the social care bill uh of
which there were you know a number of uh
disquiet and tory mps on this uh where
does that go well i mean this is so
interesting because hey you say it's not
that unusual to lose your place in a
speech but if you listen to seasoned
broadcasters i mean anna you're a
seasoned broadcaster have you ever lost
your place for 20 seconds i mean it's
really unusual
you don't want to hear what the gallery
is saying to me
[Laughter]
um but parking that for a second the the
problem with the social care bill is
obviously there was kind of strategic
there were strategic mistakes made there
were tactical mistakes made there was
obviously insufficient pitch rolling and
there was insufficient um gathering of
support and loyalty among mps but much
more fundamental than that it is a
terrible idea you know when you're
looking at a scheme which everybody pays
into in which care costs are capped a
flat rate which leaves somebody with a
500 000 pound property with the vast
majority of that property still intact
with 414 000 pounds still in assets at
the time of their death while somebody
with a hundred thousand pound property
only has fourteen thousand pounds worth
in assets at the time of their death
you're looking at a direct
redistribution
of money from the poorest to the richest
now it is extraordinary that they
thought that this would fly it's
extraordinary that they thought
they must have been counting on such
slavish loyalty from um the so-called
red wall mps from this new intake you
know they're quite inexperienced many of
them are inexperienced in politics let
alone in parliament they must have been
relying on that but they have relied on
it too heavily to cover the absolute
disastrous nature of this idea yeah and
the problem is katie this it's another
own goal a bit like the owen patterson's
second jobs affair this was a very
generous policy which has now had
terrible pr
exactly and you had a situation where
ultimately boris johnson did over
promise and under deliver on this he
pitched it as his government solving
social care suggesting they you know
were on the brink of doing this
and then what happened in reality was
they changed the scheme after mps voted
for a tax rise something they really
didn't want to do just to now find out
that people could actually lose their
home when boris johnson said no one
would and i think that it's just again
this frustration that there is lots of
things that tory mps think they can
shout about but if you keep promising
the world it starts to look as though a
disappointment all your you know going
back on your word and it's quite an
expensive way to go back on your word
um should we move on to the daily
telegraph i mean we've seen a number of
uh different measures today announced um
northern ireland for example please work
from home if you can scotland deciding
not to roll out its uh vaccine passport
scheme further into hospitality and
accepting lateral flow tests urging
people to get lateral flow test if you
go anywhere like christmas shopping for
example um but the daily telegraph still
debating what's happening here in the uk
compared to
europe zoe and the question they're
posing here is does the astrazeneca
vaccine give longer or in indeed
different protection
well that i mean that's you you've hit
the nail on the head though haven't you
because this purports to be a story
about which vaccine lasts the longest
and actually it's a story about why
we're better than europe and why we're
doing better than europe um and when you
really drill into the story the the
chief exec of astrazeneca isn't actually
making huge claims they're saying they
seem the antibody results seem to drop
off but the t cell results remain really
strong with the astrazeneca which isn't
necessarily the case with a lot of other
vaccines but he certainly the press
release certainly hasn't come out and
said we're definitely the best vaccine
everybody else's vaccine it is inferior
but what they've done what the telegraph
has done is parlayed this into a grudge
match effectively against european
nations who originally said they didn't
want to use this vaccine on the under
65s because only over 65s because the
evidence wasn't there for his efficacy
now that you know maybe the eu
nations were over cautious maybe they
should have taken a kind of speed first
and safety second um approach and maybe
we have been proven right but the the
notion that that their
sudden spikes and covert rates compared
to ours can be can be accounted for by
their decision
maliciously to ignore our vaccine
it's just telegraph fancy to be honest
this reminds me of the male in the 90s
and that every second week they'd have a
story about whether tomatoes could boost
your fertility or whether something else
would kill your fertility or whether two
tight underpants would do such and such
i mean it was basically an agenda-driven
thing which tiny tiny scientific kind of
evidence would be
marshaled into vast splashy news pieces
to make what was effectively an
ideological point women get a move on
having kids eu hands off our vaccines
yes and what about the this narrative
there was there was a lot of pushback on
social media from scientists about this
narrative katie but fundamentally the
idea is that you open early and you and
the virus seeks out the unvaccinated but
it's better to do that in the summer
than it is in the winter and therefore
the winter is controllable now has that
has that narrative been paying off do
you think
yeah i mean i think if you're comparing
the uk to
europe and really troubling scenes
it's hard to work out what one exact
thing particularly because no one really
wants to predict where covert is going
and you might think that one country is
doing well you don't know how it's going
to look in a few weeks time but i i do
think that uh in government that they
feel vindicated that decision to open
earlier get rid of restrictions when
lots of countries in europe ultimately
still had them and went slower i think
on astrazeneca in a way
it just is a political vaccine if you
think about how you know when that
vaccine first came out and you had
people like emmanuel macron saying it
was a quasi-ineffective it almost did
just get torn up in kind of eu uk
relations and so i think we have to wait
to see what the data's at but i do think
astrazeneca
whichever side is talking about whether
it's uk or some in the eu it tends to
somehow be embroiled in these in these
various political um elements
well let's just show you the metro not
we've mentioned it anyway haven't we
which is uh testive shopping get
yourself a lateral flow test before you
go out present hunting and relief too as
nicolas sturgeon backs off this
extension to the passport scheme to
things like pubs restaurants cafes
theaters and cinemas which of course
many parts of europe have at the moment
as well don't they so we'll watch what
happens um with those cases in europe
and indeed here of course too plenty
more still to come the windrush victims
still without compensation four years
after the scandal first emerged we'll
discuss that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now zoe williams
and katie balls welcome back to both of
you um so amazingly it is four years
since the windrush scandal broke zoe and
the guardian pointing out to us that
only five percent of windrush victims
have so far received any compensation
i mean it's really extraordinary at
least in the first year after these
events it was absolutely extraordinary
that the home office wasn't moving
faster to repair the damage they'd done
because the stories that came out were
really
really something you know people who'd
been deported to jamaica and rendered
homeless having no contacts there
having been having lived here since they
were one year old people who'd been
refused treatment on the nhs people
who'd lost their jobs in their homes i
mean real acts of cruelty and you know
unjust acts because all of these cases
once they had light shone on them but
these
people were completely legitimate
citizens of the united kingdom the
reason they'd been rejected was because
they couldn't find their primary school
rep school reports from you know 1971
which none of us could do um so there
was it was a terrible act of injustice
and i think if we had a normal
functioning government there would the
reparations would have been made
what i doubt is that you know having
failed to make those reparations in the
first year since the scandal it's no
surprise at all that they haven't been
made since because normal government
business has not been really working
at least since the since 2019 when the
johnson administration took over but
probably since 2017 when theresa may
lost her workable majority and spent the
rest of her time just trying to make
brexit happen so i think what we're just
seeing here is the kind of sharp edge of
what happens when government gives up on
regular
critidian business of looking after its
citizens and it's absolutely tragic
katie do you want to dwell on that or
should we see theresa may in fact um you
know in the front row of the pew uh for
sir david amos's
funeral today um alongside john major
david cameron the current prime minister
um these are amazing scenes aren't they
for for someone with a you know a great
sense of humor as everybody remembered
in the service today and yesterday in
fact
exactly and i think you see everyone
putting politics aside for one day
coming together
and i think that uh you know people from
different parties showing up to pay
tribute to dave sir david amos and i
think it's only been recently that this
happened i think lots of um people in
parliament uh colleagues people who work
in parliament are still actually trying
to come to terms with it and i think it
still feels very close and very raw and
but you do hope today and that service
and separate to the funeral to the
private funeral but this memorial
service uh which the pope sent a message
for um you know commending sir david
amos's contribution to public life um is
going to be getting some of that healing
process
yes the pope's message said his holiness
recalls with gratitude sir david's years
of devoted public service guided by his
strong catholic faith as you said and
evidenced in his deep concern for the
poor and the disadvantaged and the
people of south end of course wanted to
be the father of the house so he could
start every uh speech
and uh start first to make the case for
southend being a city which of course
retrospectively it has been
um
zoey yeah i mean it's i i think this is
really one of the few moments of
complete non-partisanship we can
remember in recent times it's you know
he was not just
a quite well-liked um conservative mp he
was considered on pakistan himself in
the sense that he was very much a
constituency mp rather than a career or
um ideological one and
it makes it all the sadder because
obviously
when you're when you've given your life
to public service he would there's
absolutely no sense in which he would
think he would have thought of himself
as a lightning rod for this kind of act
of violence as no mp ever should
well zoe and katie thank you both very
much indeed and we look forward to
hearing more from both of you uh at 11
o'clock when you take us through uh
today's news and tomorrow's headlines as
well